[Musique]
je crois alors fait une petite
expérience je demandé à tous ceux qui
n'ont pas de téléphone portable
le levé l'homme n'a pas beaucoup envie à
ceux qui en possèdent quand est ce que
vous pouvez les villes m ce qui a poussé
deux a alors on voit que la majorité de
la salle possède au moins un téléphone
portable ou tu dis moi j'en possède 9 2
comme beaucoup d'allemandes à quel point
nous sommes pris la 5 ans aujourd'hui la
technologie permet à ceux qui ne sont
même pas l'écrire vous pouvoir utiliser
nous avons atteint un certain niveau de
développement technologique
malheureusement il suffit d'aller dans
le service où se rencontrent il ya
encore pas mal de choses pas mal de
problèmes auxquels la technologie peut
apporter des solutions et c'est ce que
je tente de faire dans mon quotidien
alors je suis comblé sur la divine et je
suis vladimir ça va je suis ingénieur en
informatique est un grand passionné
depuis le bas âge
chaque fois qu'on vous fait déjouer les
démonter savoir comment fonctionnait
bien sûr dans les annales de fusées à
savoir au départ manama mais cette
passion a grandi avec moi ils me joins à
l'adolescence mon argent de poche
si ces technologies mais kamal du dif y
vivent en témoigne le professeur le coup
mais ça m'a suivi et en grandissant
après l'obtention de mon baccalauréat t
j'ai eu la chance d'étudier leurs dalles
au canada pour faire du génie
informatique alors que ceux qui ne
savent pas gêner informatique c'est une
moitié d'informatique et moitié
l'électronique
cinq ans après ils finissent elle s'est
donc décidée durant prix pays met en
avant avant cela il fallait que je
travaille un peu partout aux finissants
donc du coup j'ai cherché du boulot ça
n'a pas été chose aisée
j'ai fait quelques petits boulots mais
au bout d'un moment j'ai décidé de
rappeler pour voir la famille d'avoir
mais aussi les opportunités d'affaires
que je pouvais le faire
tina façon une fois que je suis entré
le constat a été quand qu'en termes de
technologie il y avait encore beaucoup
de choses à faire
le terrain était vierge donc c'est tout
naturellement que j'ai décidé d'analyser
le marché
cela m'a pris un peu de temps parce
qu'il fallait que je me réadapte au pays
et à la mentalité les populations et à
la mentalité des populations mais c'est
tout naturellement qu'il fallait que je
trouve un projet quelque part du but et
alors c'est venu tout de suite un jeu ou
bien est-ce que vous avez remarqué au
burkina faso attendons beaucoup au fait
des démarches administratives
attendons pour payer les factures
nous attendons pour se soigner à
l'hôpital
nous attendons même au restaurant
universitaire pour prendre son retard il
faut attendre
et le comble avez vous déjà essayé
d'aller en banque
c'est infernal la paire un poids plus y
aller c'est pour faire un dépôt c'était
une personne de deux minutes j'ai dû
attendre deux heures
alors je me suis dit non ce n'est pas
aussi faut faire quelque chose par
rapport à cela avec des amis nous avions
un groupe watsa dans lequel nous
échangeons des opportunités d'affaires
alors je suis allé de l'avant c'était
tout frustré ou sinon je leur ai dit non
sur l'enfant je voulais faire un dépôt
j'ai attendu deux heures faut continuer
solution nous allons commencer à cogiter
est ce qu'on peut faire une solution est
né nous avons décidé de mettre en place
une application mobile banque est
complet à l'intérieur de laquelle oui on
construit on pouvait consulter son solde
des virements localiser les succursales
en chèques et à côté on intégrait un
goût du qui permettrait de prendre son
ticket sur le téléphone portable à
distance
pour nous c'était génial on avait l'idée
du siècle c'était sans compter sur
l'édifice alors une fois qu'on a validée
devions développer notre solution moi
bien sûr je suis informaticien mais je
n'avais pas des créances en
développement mobile alors nous avons
expérimenté deux cas d'avant en passant
par un développeur extérieur alors le
monsieur la pilote argent il a disparu
donc nous on fait alors une somme vous
êtes passé par des gens à l'extérieur
vous être expliquée alors essayons
quelqu'un de local a fait sans compter
sur l'homme si le groupe n'avait donc
une fois de plus nous avons payé une
avance
il nous a fait tourner ils nous
envoyaient des roues de travail debout
le projet de temps à autre mais rien de
convaincant on a perdu énormément de
temps mais comme on dit souvent un mal
peut apporter un bien et c'est comme ça
que nous avons décidé de créer une
entreprise une entreprise dans laquelle
vous me montrez nous ce serait là et
qu'ils allaient travailler sur nos
projets mais aussi sur les projets des
autres et c'est comme ça
nous avons commencé à développer nos
solutions une fois la solution
development
il fallait parler maintenant au parc
alors sont allés voir banques de la
place pour présenter notre solution ils
ont fait comprendre que lui votre
solution elle est bien elle est
intéressante mais ça ne va pas marcher
avec nous pourquoi parce que c'était une
application mobile mobile par deux
ouvertes
grand public se connecte à internet et
qui se connecte à leur service
il avait peur qu'on pirates nous ont dit
non donc tout ça a été un 30 du matin
parce que ça fait quand même pas mal du
temps ils travailleront sur ses
prévisions alors jalons cogiter si les
banques ne veulent pas de l'application
bancaire
que pouvons nous faire nous avons donc
décidé de laisser le petit bancaires et
de développer juste l'application qui
s'occupera des files d'attentes et c'est
ainsi que nous allons poursuivre nos
développements il avons créé notre
application s'appelle leila allons line
up c'est quoi de manière très simple
voyez la borne éthique et du prix du
ticket se trouve dans votre succursale à
pain qu'on disait allez alors line up
c'est la bonne chose mais sur votre
téléphone portable
en effet à distance vous pouvez juste
prendre votre téléphone portable
sélectionnez enfin sélectionner une
succursale et vous voyez la longueur de
la file d'attenté donc pas il ya 58
personnes devant moi je suis le seigneur
et je passe dans 1h30
donc ce que décidée que par ses dents
1h30 et à ce moment je reçois une
notification par sms 30 minutes à la
havane où je peux me dire je suis occupé
mais je suis libre buzzer alors judici
de passer dans deux heures et quand la
longueur de la file vingt deux heures
j'aurai en masse et ira automatiquement
un ticket donc vous voyez que c'est une
solution capote qui règle un problème
celui de la vente
alors quels sont les bénéfices de cette
solution
des gens comme une entreprise elle
permet de désengorger les salles data je
suis sûr que vous êtes déjà allé
plusieurs fois dans une succursale
et il ya tellement de monde que vous
restez doux avec la danse est deuxième
deuxième avantage c'est qu'il permet il
y rend le travail agréable où les agents
parce qu'il ya moins de monde moins de
pression le travail est facile alors le
troisième avantage est le plus important
pour moi c'est que vous voyez qu'on vous
prenne et l'application mobile aino vous
pouvez remplir votre fiche du pipeau
votre nouveau riche dur était à l'avance
vous arrivez dans la succursale l'argent
directement aux fiches remplies
suso novateur qu'est ce que ça permet de
caler sa perle du cannet du temps de
traitement selon nos estimations en
moyenne ça permet de gagner six minutes
par jour et par agent alors si vous
prenez une succursale qu'à 24 agents
pendant quatre agents ça lui permet ça
leur permet de gagner 24 minutes
et selon nos estimations encore une fois
de plus une opération dure en moyenne
trois minutes
donc en gros pour cette succursale
ça promet de gagner de traiter 8
personnes par jour en plus en une
semaine ont fait quarante personnes en
europe moins 160 personnes en une année
1920 personnes voyez que c'est gros et
aux pèlerins juifs le peut dire que
c'est un avantage mais qu'en est il de
particulier
alors déjà outre le fait de gagner du
temps
cette solution vous permet de faire vos
occupations en toute quiétude
cela veut dire que c'est sûr que
plusieurs voies et moyens j'ai déjà
testé ça d'aller dans la succursale de
prendre mon ticket en lui disant qu'on
ya beaucoup de gens vais aller vaquer à
nos occupations et weny et quand
j'arrive subi
retour est passée et là je suis frustré
avec cette solution c'est vaquer
tranquillement à leurs occupations
vous prenez votre ticket alors là il
n'est pas la seule solution technologies
qui existent
il ya beaucoup de choses que l'on peut
faire vous la rive beaucoup de solutions
c'est un petit peu réglé des problèmes
tels et tels que pourrait développer une
application facilite et
l'alphabétisation ou alors une solution
pour faciliter les démarches
administratives
quand on voit comment les entrepreneurs
peinent avec ça ça pourrait être du
jouanno donc mon message par là et en
fait d'encourager les jeunes africains à
développer des solutions qui pourront
les problèmes des solutions qui pourront
changer l'affût changer nos échanges et
vous je vous remercie